we had this WWE simulator and I went
through it let's take a look at what
Adan feel
some what the Rock it's
[Applause]
[Music]
cookie
okay we are here in Riad and I'm here
with my niece's husband Muhammad she how
are you Muhammad aldah I'm good I'm good
you must be better even better
that I'm here we've also got the she mu
taka with us he's a specialist in crypto
and Islamic finin brother oh sorry yeah
Bitcoin not crypto there you go that's
the new Metro statistically wise this is
the fastest largest roll out of a Metro
System ever in history in the world say
that again say one more time fastest and
largest roll out of a Metro system in
the world in history really yeah they're
doing the whole the whole city in one go
so tell us where we now so this is a
place where where
okay yeah so tell us it's it's a nice
area to walk RI next
to oh this is a famous place I don't
know I'll be honest with you I don't
know why it's so famous this is this is
a famous thing okay we here with
beautiful princes of Saudi Arabia who
have a real love for Islam we've had a
real conversation with them and they are
now intermingling as you can see with
the cheaters
I'm
beautiful I don't have the same courage
as these guys when it comes
to I love their smell you know yeah I
love
that you're you're a real M what did you
call it benevolent one it's called
benevolent control oh I love it
benevolent because without control
there's no discipline yes without
discipline there's no order brother
because
discipline
is the Norms of creation by Allah tala
yes he created Norms we call
them not only beyond
that that's what the is without
discipline there is no so these guys
have got like okay like you know mini
Eiffel Tower here you can see the view
here they've try to create a kind of um
artificial Lake I don't know what to
call this but is it does look nice you
got these screens that they put and
there's another Mall here with a similar
Vibe it's called Granada mall I think it
is very
nice yeah so this is something common in
uh in these in these lamps you find this
kind of artificial kind of the scens and
stuff like but it's quite nice you know
what I mean tell me more about this my
first time
here is all
right you can see this is like a they
they create this kind of effects you
know what I mean so yeah it is it is
nice this is one of the main attractions
here in riat yeah it's called Boulevard
world if you've been to Dubai and you
know there's like a mall where it's got
like a section for each of the
nationalities this is taking the same
kind of concept and trying to run with
it what you realize about Sai Arabia is
that it's got a very vibrant night
culture would you agree with this in
Riyad yeah me night the night starts
from 9:00 p.m. yeah that's everyone
that's when everyone wakes up is it yeah
yeah it seems like the thing is uh you
see kids with families at that time
which is very strange they come with
young kids going outside at that
time yes it is something that if you if
you saw a kid on a bouncy castle at 1:00
in the morning in England you call the
police here is a normal thing